“There’s a monster under my bed!”
Almost every parent has heard their kids make
the claim, and it’s usually nothing more
than some unusual shadows, or at worst a household
pest scurrying around.
Parents usually tell the child to go back
to sleep, or maybe try to dispel their fears
by shining a light under the bed.
It’s a childhood rite of passage, and one
that usually passes soon enough.
But for one young woman in Missouri, the monster
under her bed was very real - and very dangerous.
SCP-3887-A doesn’t seem like she belongs
in a containment facility.
She’s a twenty-four-year-old woman who lived
a quiet life in her hometown until things
went horribly wrong.
She doesn’t appear to possess any special
abilities and the Foundation is able to contain
her without any difficulty.
But wherever she goes, death and destruction
follow.
It’s not her doing, but there is something
out there that will not stand to see her hurt
in any way.
Her personal monster under the bed is very
protective.
Something another young woman found out the
hard way.
Incident 3887-A-1 occurred in 2014, when the
young woman was attending a party with her
girlfriend.
Her partner was berating and humiliating her
in front of the guests, which was apparently
not a rare occurrence in their relationship.
Suddenly, something manifested under a nearby
table and before she could react, her girlfriend
was brutally mauled by the unknown creature.
Her limbs were completely severed from her
body, and died at the scene.
An undercover SCP agent who was implanted
within the local authorities, made their way
to the scene as soon as possible and found
SCP-3887-A in a state of shock.
And who can blame her, after the encounter
she just had with what would come to be known
as SCP-3887-B.
While 3887-A is a normal human with no unusual
abilities or characteristics, 3887-B is anything
but.
Foundation scientists have described it as
a humanoid entity standing over seven feet
tall.
Its skin is greenish-grey, and it has two
long, sharp horns on its head.
Its head and neck are covered in thick black
hair, and its eyes are a striking yellow color.
Its mouth is full of sharp fangs similar to
that of a shark, and its elongated arms allow
it to move on all fours.
It has a long, hairless tail that resembles
a rat’s, and possesses both male and female
reproductive organs.
No one knows where it came from, but they
do have an idea why it’s sticking around.
SCP-3887-B seems to be bonded to SCP-3887-A,
and can appear in any darkened area within
a five-meter radius around her.
While its favorite location is under 3887-A’s
bed, which has since been brought to the facility,
it appears to be able to teleport wherever
she is, just as it did during the party when
it made its presence brutally clear.
It has odd eating patterns, and is able to
gain nourishment from practically any object,
whether it resembles what we would consider
food or not.
Its favorite treats for example?
SCP-3887-A’s socks.
But it does have one weakness that has been
useful in containing it - it can’t stand
the light.
And it doesn’t just hate it, when 3887-B
is exposed to bright light, it develops blisters
and wounds and flees to the nearest dark area.
SCP Foundation scientists are at a loss to
explain exactly what this creature is though,
and SCP-3887-B seems to be a chimera of multiple
animals with multiple types of DNA.
It possesses DNA similar to humans, but also
from a type of Oryx with similar horns, as
well as a rat with the same type of tail,
as well as a common cane toad.
And then there’s even some DNA that doesn’t
resemble any known creature in nature.
Studying it further has been trickier though,
because it seems to have the effect of disrupting
any electronic recording devices near it,
causing lasting damage if it’s in proximity
to them for too long.
There has been one bit of good news for SCP
Scientists though, because while it has shown
that it can be extremely violent, it has not
attacked Foundation officials…
Not yet at least.
Its good behavior may not have anything to
do with how it personally feels about Foundation
staff though, and is instead all thanks to
SCP-3887-A. 3887-A has been completely cooperative
since she was taken into custody by the Foundation.
She doesn’t perceive them as a threat, and
so far it seems like SCP-3887-B is following
her lead.
It has a strong emotional connection to the
young woman, and when they’re alone they
show affectionate behavior towards each other.
While the creature does not seem to like the
Foundation, it doesn’t seem like it wants
to become hostile - unless the Foundation
gives it a reason to.
When 3887-A was interviewed following the
tragic incident, by undercover Foundation
Agent Bellamy, she was panicked and terrified.
She admitted that her partner often treated
her badly, and believed that the creature
was trying to protect her.
She admitted that she had seen the creature
before, she even had a name for it, she called
her Grenda.
3887-A always thought she was crazy, now there
was proof though - she was not imagining the
monster under her bed.
Describing Grenda as her “boogeyman”,
the young woman talked about how she had known
the creature since she was a child.
She grew up in an old house in the country
that was full of strange sounds that made
it sound like something was in her room with
her, and sometimes she would even catch a
glimpse of what she thought was a monster
under her bed watching her.
She tried telling her parents but they thought
she was making the whole thing up, and even
she was forced to wonder if she was hallucinating
or had somehow imagined the whole thing.
But then when she was a teenager, all of her
doubts were put to bed.
One night 3887-A’s parents were loudly fighting,
a sadly not rare occurrence in their household,
and she locked herself in her room to get
away from them.
As she hid, Grenda emerged from under her
bed for the first time - and talked with her.
And she isn’t the only one that Grenda is
willing to speak with, she’s also sat down
for her own interviews with Foundation researchers.
Well the researcher sat down, while Grenda
remained under the bed.
Foundation Researcher Dr. Tanner interviewed
Grenda, who was cordial but guarded and remained
deeply protective of the girl under her protection.
She expressed feeling guilty for getting 3887-A
in trouble, but Dr. Tanner assured her that
3887-A was not being punished and was being
kept at the Foundation for her own safety.
He offered that they could keep Grenda safe
as well, but she responded that as long as
3887-A remained safe, then she would be as
well.
She explained that her kind fed on the anxiety
of children, which was why they lurked under
their beds.
She was apparently only supposed to remain
with this girl until she was ten or so, but
became attached and decided to stay with her
which was against the rules of her people
and as a result she had been exiled from her
home.
At this point, Grenda offered to show herself
to the researcher and began to emerge from
under the bed.
Unfortunately, as has become standard when
attempting to document SCP-3887-B, all of
the recording equipment malfunctioned and
was unable to record Grenda’s appearance.
The Foundation continued to have questions
about this pair and their strange relationship,
and interviewed SCP-3887-A again, this time
by a Dr. Garden.3887-A told Dr. Garden that
she had been sleeping well and had been spending
lots of time talking to the entity under her
bed.
That led Dr. Garden to bring up a theory about
how 3887-B had come to exist.
The young woman speculated that Grenda may
have been created from her fears.
One of her first memories of being scared
was when she went to an aquarium and a massive
bull shark came close to the glass where it
bared its rows and rows of shark teeth, the
exact same kind of teeth that Grenda possessed.
In fact all of the traits Grenda exhibited,
like her rat tail, seemed to connect to childhood
fears that she had experienced.
3887-A always felt alone as a little girl,
and she believed that she might have manifested
Grenda as a companion who was there exactly
when she needed her to be.
This raised the question of whether SCP-3887-B
really was the unnatural entity, or if SCP-3887-A
is the source of the entity’s existence.
The next interview with SCP-3887-B would raise
even more questions.
When Dr. Garden went to interview SCP-3887-B,
it was clear the entity was agitated.
Grenada became hostile as soon as Dr. Garden
entered the room, saying she was hungry and
didn’t want to answer questions.
When Dr. Garden said that 3887-A had provided
it with socks, the entity reacted with anger.
The socks were just a snack.
To live it needed fear.
3887-B fed off human emotions - specifically
paranoia and anxiety.
SCP-3887-A used to be full of them, but now
she was unusually calm in the facility and
it was having a bad effect on her companion.
When Dr. Garden promised to talk to supervisors,
the creature became more agitated - and reached
out from under the bed, grabbing Dr. Garden
and pulling her under the bed.
No one knew what would happen to Dr. Garden
under the bed and SCP-3887-A was quickly summoned
to try to calm her companion down, but when
she called for Grenda, there was no response.
It was feared that Dr. Garden had been lost
to the area under the bed that no one can
access, but then thirteen minutes later, the
doctor suddenly emerged from under the bed.
She was bruised, soaking wet, and missing
articles including shoes, socks, and her glasses.
Later Interviews with Dr. Garden would give
the best picture yet of where SCP-3887-B comes
from.
Dr. Garden described being pulled under the
bed, which then led somewhere else entirely.
She fell for fifteen seconds, still held by
SCP-3887-B, but when she landed she was alone
in a large cave made of black rock with purple
gems in the walls.
The cave contained a waterfall, a lake, and
what looked like SCP-3887’s secret home.
It was filled with pictures of the girl she
was bonded to, a violin, some stuffed animals
- and large piles of the girl’s socks.
SCP-3887-B was there in the cave with her
too, watching her.
She would catch glimpses of the creature - her
white fangs and her yellow eyes.
She was terrified and ran screaming, trying
to find any way out of there as the creature
pursued her.
She couldn’t evade her forever though, and
eventually Grenda grabbed Dr. Garden.
She was lifted into the air as Grenda bared
her shark like teeth, but instead of eating
her, the creature instead took off the doctor’s
socks, and thanked her before somehow sending
her back up into the darkness.
She then found herself back under the bed,
surrounded by worried SCP personnel.
Since then, SCP-3887-B has not brought anyone
else into its home, it seems feeding on Dr.
Garden’s fear was enough for the time being,
and the situation has remained stable since.
The SCP Foundation has been able to develop
relatively simple containment procedures for
the two entities that make up SCP-3887, as
neither is currently hostile.
The two are contained within a standard humanoid
containment cell with the bed at the center.
SCP-3887-A is given standard amenities, a
healthy diet including a vitamin for some
minor health issues, and her own control over
the lights in the cell.
She has requested and been given a gaming
system for entertainment and up-to-date entertainment
media but was denied access to the internet,
a pet cat, and access to the on-site recreation
areas due to the risk of SCP-3887-B getting
loose.
The facility does have plans in place in case
“Grenda” decides to become hostile again
though.
While SCP-3887-A normally maintains control
of the lights in her cell, the Foundation
has a fail-safe installed so they can turn
them up at any time.
Since SCP-3887-B reacts negatively to bright
light, the lights can be used as a security
system to send her retreating back under the
bed until she can be pacified through other
measures.
While neither of the SCP-3887 entities appears
to be seeking to escape, it is impossible
to predict where and how 3887-B would act
if 3887-A was free from her cell again, and
whether she would attempt to harm those she
perceives as a threat to 3887-A as she did
in the past.
So for now, the Foundation is focused on keeping
both of them pacified - which, in the case
of 3887-B, means a healthy supply of socks.
But there’s one other lingering question
the Foundation hasn’t solved.
SCP-3887-B referenced being exiled from its
kin for breaking the rules and was confined
to a cave.
That means there might be others like “Grenda”
out there - and they may be more aggressive
and less scrupulous than she is.
While no other specimens have been found,
the SCP Foundation will be keeping a careful
eye on any reports of monsters lurking under
children’s beds.
They might just be telling the truth.
Now for another entity that lurks in a seemingly
bottomless pit, check out “SCP-354 - The
Red Pool”, or watch this video instead.